[Music]
since September 2006 Kevin Vinod has
been writing for gamespot.com
but sadly all good things must come to
an end Kevin you were leaving us at the
end of this week I am on a brand new
adventure I am first of all before we
get a little bit nostalgic you tell us
about your brand-new adventure
I can i I'm joining trying worlds to be
writing the the English stuff say I
write for a living and so I have a good
good command of words I'm actually very
for clumped in emotional the last few
days but yes I'll be joining trion
worlds to be writing the English
dialogue for their upcoming Korean MMO
suite which is called pavilion so there
there it is there's can I can I say can
I say the games name on air is I
considered like thank you did and we're
gonna do fire me
so was this something you always thought
you might do did you I know your first
love was was was writing about games or
at least it was back you know 10 years
ago and nine years ago it was this
always something you thought you might
get into I mean you just never know it's
not something that I got into this for I
got into this because this is what I
wanted to be doing here at GameSpot and
so I still remember looking back you
know you start a new job or whatever and
you always have like that HR interview
where they have like what do you want to
be doing in five years there's like I
don't know this is this I never imagined
I'd be here doing this this was the pie
in the sky this was the dream I have no
idea what I want to be doing I mean in
time obviously we all want to grow as
people we all want to do try new things
and use our talents in different ways
and and this opportunity came up and I
decided to grab it even though I'm
terrified yeah I'm terrified more
terrified actually than when I got the
job at GameSpot which was I lived on the
East Coast I drove I put everything I
had that I could fit in my car which was
mostly game stuff and a little bit of
clothes and I drove more was it yet the
Baltimore area yeah totally I lived in
Columbia Maryland and I drove to
actually went to work that morning
was work then work I worked at a company
called national data care which did
which wrote software and did service for
nursing for nursing home banks I was a
wife so I went to work for my last day
of work with everything already in my
car and then when work was over I got in
my car and drove 2,300 miles in three
days across the across the United States
and discovered that there are some
states I would move to in some states
that I would not route 80 all the way
across like I just picked up route 80 in
Pennsylvania and then just zoom all the
way across the country so one of the
questions that people ask us a lot is
like how you broke into this industry I
remember you from my own time I'm coming
up on ten years being a GameSpot member
in August
back then you were a prolific member of
the community you were a moderator and
then I remember seeing you right on the
site so headed how did that happen what
were you doing freelancing where I know
you were big part of the GameSpot
community as well so I was a big I was a
big part of the GameSpot community just
in the forums and stuff like that on the
forums I think had a sort of a different
timbre back then as well and and so I
wrote a lot of reader reviews I was a
big part of the forums and then I became
a moderator and then I started writing
for a site called inside gamer online it
sort of just still exists it's called
smash pad now but as you know is one of
those things were a bunch of people that
love games get together and write for
free I wasn't making any money from it
or anything but then but apparently I
was pretty good at it and I stand then I
started freelancing for GameSpy cool and
my first review my first paid review
ever was for a game called crime life
gang wars I still remember it today a
one star review on GameSpy starring
starring famous rap group d12
oh yeah Eminem's posse oh yeah Detroit
yeah yeah totally great great game it
was terrible the highest score I ever
gave at GameSpy was three and a half out
of five stars I did a lot of handheld
licensed games okay but I think the best
game I ever played was a ps2 game called
barnyard based on it's based on of the
movie
barnyard was called barnyard but yeah it
was sort of a it was sort of yeah it's
not just what happened still like Peter
when you first started riding it was did
you get all those drags as well just
like the do freelancers just get the
crap I lucked out my first review is the
Dreamcast for PC Magazine celery yeah
Dreamcast the Dreamcast okay when I
first started reviewing here I think the
first one I did was Tekken 3d with the
3ds Wow is that Sun right yeah I don't
know
Janak it was Kevin reviews editor when
you came on no that happened like two
years after well at least that was like
when he was officially when you when you
started Justin just in Calibre's yeah
right doing that yeah so what was your
progression done through cuz you
actually started if I remember correctly
but you were like I started a magazine I
said not button mashing now tourneys
tournaments from the TV that's also the
way it happened was so I was doing all
this stuff for a game spy and freely
thing and when I knew the game stops but
the game stopped yeah I'm doing one of
those [ __ ] out I've I knew the
GameSpot staff already I died you know I
chatted with them at e3 and stuff cuz
I've been to III for like three years
for inside gamer online and and you know
sometimes you know we just chat and say
hi and I got this call out of the blue
from Jody Robinson to tell me that this
position had opened for a tournament
coordinator and they'd like to bring me
out I mean none of this happened because
I applied for it just out of the blue I
get a phone call and then sure enough
like a couple days later GameSpot flew
me out here and then it was the weirdest
job interview ever because I didn't feel
like I was interviewing for a job I felt
like they were interviewing for the
chance to have me it was the strangest
thing like it was they were so
complimentary it's like this is just a
you know you know just a formality we
just really want you to have this job
it's like that makes me feel good that's
a good feeling who interview right oh
gosh well Jody Hank that niekirk was in
charge of of that bit of the games group
at that time because we had Game Center
I don't know if you remember a Game
Center but we there was a there was Game
Center and tournaments was part of that
because we alt there was also a little
multiplayer client to use to connect
with other people and games game set
didn't last a long time but there had
been a lot of staff brought on for her
game center I think Sam Parker might
have been one of those people looking
back I don't remember but I think he
might have been and and so I got the job
and I did the scary move and I did
tournaments for a while along with you
know rich Gallup was usually the host of
tournament TV and it was usually the the
person there but I handled all the
behind the scenes stuff for tournaments
I did all the preliminary stuff until
like go down the final two but it didn't
take long and I was sort of
transitioning I think Alex was the one
who was alex navaro
was the one who has signed reviews in
those days and and he knew my work from
previous and he he took a chance on me
and said hey here's the thing I want you
to review some war game some you know
American Revolution war game like okay
fine
ya have to take that matter of flags and
but then just a few games in and I was
being trusted with some other things
that were a little bit bigger like
command & Conquer 3 was probably my
first what I would say big review before
that most of those games had been
relatively inconsequential yeah Thomas
had Craigs
which one was Greg's Greg Cassavetes C&C
Greg Kasavin was C&C red alert I was ok
he went to Red Alert he did how he did
do some stuff with command & Conquer 3
before it was released but he joined the
team close to that game's release and so
Red Alert 3 was his I think his big
project there before he moved it was
Greg gone by the time you started here
no Greg was still here when I first
started but he wasn't here for very long
and then of course I was here for 4
Gershman gate yes of cause the following
year presumably I was a fan of of Ryan
and Jeff and of course yeah absolutely
when I first started here can I can I
share you a little story I think I've
shared this story before about Ryan
Davis the first time I saw him in person
was when I I was I think it was for the
interview not my first I was either my
interviewer the first day on the job and
I walked into the editorial area cuz
Jodi was showing me around and he was
playing Super Monkey Ball for the Wii
and he was clearly frustrating the first
thing I ever heard Ryan Davis say in
person was [ __ ] [ __ ]
and that was that's my that truly is my
fondest Ryan Davis memory unless you
count the the day he was you know he he
told me how wonderful it was that I
could buy Pepsi for 25 cents oh yeah
yeah the cbsi vending machine yeah so
you know but these are guys that I just
looked up to and actually I felt very
awkward when I started but when that
happened because everything there was
this big surge of people who have doctor
when they needed brought Schumaker
laughs yeah did you arrive did you feel
like stuck between a rock and because
you just got any ice creams I did in a
way it's like well what do I do now
I you know kiss because these guys I
looked up to but I I was never part of
that core group because I was new they
had a year's worth of rapport I was
still yeah an experience and I was still
trying to fit into things and so when it
happened I was just I just flabbergasted
the day it happened I had to go on on
tournaments tournament TV that day for
the Ace Combat six Turner right yeah and
I just sat there like one tone the whole
time just staring ahead I was just flour
I didn't know what to do and of course
everybody started dropping like flies
and part of that was they were friends
they they they had an idea they were
doing something new together and but I
wasn't really part of that core crowd
and so I was stuck feeling like I was
left behind and what was I gonna do I
you know I driven 2,300 miles for my
dream job it's you know I I wasn't ready
coming to conquer 3 that's actually Red
Alert
it's rare but I did do the Red Alert
with you and speaking of your reviews
and some fun moments what are the
reviews that stick out to you as your as
your favorite reviews over your tenure I
know you've given a couple of tens you
Robert Moton given a couple of ones as
well to ones actually okay do you want
to get a test okay we're doing a tassel
I've said it's a whale in engineering
who scrub and I basically have some
great and marry pasties over to me just
put this is a fun test I like this so we
have a bunch of facts about Kevin vine
or isn't a nine-year tenure at games
okay let's let him get get answer my own
questions about me and first of all how
many reviews do you think I think you've
done oh God
um 600 745 oh nice what's your what's
your last review gonna be my last review
is probably gonna be journey or the
guess who are you yeah nice yeah
and what's your actually okay well let's
do it by number first of all how many
ones did you give two four four because
I gave two 1.5 you did crimes here one
so is that what that day is good yeah I
can tell you what the 1.5 czar okay
Anubis the second or enormous to is it
says and Stalin versus Martians yes the
two ones are air control yes I'm
actually sorry this 3:103 ones low price
because the other is Revelations 2012 oh
my god because Revelations 2012 is one
of my favorite reviews of having written
it oh really not that the game was good
obviously but it was fun to write that
review and your two tens my two tens or
The Witcher 3 in Metal Gear Solid 4 yeah
yeah that's who solid ones and let's get
into some of the other ones you get it
so for one obviously these are all
broken down because our ruling a
10-point okay I didn't realize that they
were gonna be finished in like that okay
a toot sorry ten two's 27 threes
65 fours 83 fives
141 sixes 197 sevens 162 eights and 54 9
to our to tens what is your score do you
think 6.46 0.6 oh not bad it's not bad
close and how many reviews do you think
you did your first year great shirt to
wear for that common man I miss being
funny I'm working at being skinny again
people ask me that from time to time you
know for a while if you googled my name
the autofill and was weight loss oh
really for a while I remember so
apparently people were totally into the
fact that I was losing weight and sadly
I didn't stay that way and I want to try
again but anyway it's just people ask me
all the time about this when they start
when they took the Kinect that in a box
for the Xbox one it kind of stopped the
dream that's true
your shape was that game there you did
17 reviews in 2006 what do you think was
your busiest year my busiest year yeah
uh 2011 oh so close
what is it close as well 22 2010 Oh 2010
120 reviews actually take that back 2009
127 okay okay it went seven I don't know
I would never have had an idea from
starting a 2006 going through 17 and 77
89 1 2 7 and now here's the slow decline
of Kevin Bernard 112 64 59 48 and only
32 it this year yeah I mean this is what
happens to when you're put in charge of
something right so I had less time to do
my own stuff because I was hurting cats
in the form of the freelancers right um
and so you become more you know your put
your giving stuff out more and doing
stuff on your own less yes and it was
one of the things I missed actually I
missed kind of being a reviews machine
but there's also the fact that in that
time we lost a hold up we used to have a
whole department that they did a lot of
stuff but one of the things they did is
enter our stuff in the CMS in other
words our content management system we
didn't touch that stuff as authors when
I first started right there was a
department that did that so we just
wrote [ __ ] and sent it to them and they
did the refs he sub edited as well or
yeah what went to copy edit - we don't
have that either we don't have a reviews
editor either anymore Kevin sorry
and the last one your most used words in
your reviews the I hate waiting those
have been scrubbed at yeah most used
words I mean it has to be oh god I hope
it's not an adverb because I'm a staunch
anti at ver oh I wish it I hope it's
never I don't know I have no idea what
its first ones game game hope second one
I think about your podcast
gamespot know your gameplay gameplay was
my second play yeah play your words are
one game plays two words are one game
plays one word a Time Lord
okay so game plays live in here and then
you have action-adventure these are all
sort of this is the most moral boring
cloud of
ever developer series shooter story fun
that's a good I'm not the enemy of fun
worlds I love if I actually if I if I
read this all at one work one go it's a
really good sentence action-adventure
battles character combat controlled
developer dragons effect elements
enjoyable enough entertaining exciting
experience fans features feel final
flaws force fun game gameplay give hours
give hours give hours and then two eyes
together so presumably that's for two or
something oh yeah I keep levels lots
mechanics mission moments number offers
online original play powerful provides
rather role-playing series shooter story
strategy visual world sorry visual war
world years does that reads like the
back of a box of the best game ever
Kevin before we wrap this up one final
question for you what is one of the
favorite moments for your time at games
buffer come to the biggest moments what
are the moments where you thought Jesus
Christ the company of I have this job oh
my [ __ ] god I don't even know there
was a moment at I they're quite a few
one of them is sort of like meeting my
own like we all have those game heroes
that we have like game developers that
we love yes in industry people that we
love and getting to me who I always
thought of as sort of my my idol was
Ragnar tørnquist who who wrote the
longest journey which is my favorite
game of all time and worked for fun calm
who made my favorite MMO for a long time
yeah you know well anvil on steering as
well but meeting him was certainly a
highlight that was a lot of fun and so
meeting other people like that meaning
Richard Garriott's and things like that
and and and that's that stuff is always
kind of cool although I'm not I'm not
somebody that's much of a star [ __ ]
can I say this so I'm not somebody
really like that that's like oh I'm
blown away by meeting this person yeah
but there god there was there was that
that there's that kind of stuff
sometimes just getting to play
certain games and getting a chance to
review them and say what you want to say
is is always really really miss it fun
god yes yeah god yes like one of the I
mean this is terrifying for me because
I'm leaving something huge behind
something I worked like I really wanted
for so long and like sometimes I have
those moments where it's like oh I'm not
gonna write the fallout 4 review for
GameSpot and that's awful I really
wanted to do that you know and then I
think oh god I don't get the review no
man's sky or I don't get to be in the
fight for who's gonna be reviewing all
that guy or whatever like this stuff was
is really meaningful to me I'm never
going to keep writing nobody's gonna you
know every nothing's really gonna change
in terms of the things I love I'm gonna
keep playing all these games I'm gonna
write about them because I can't not
because I'm opinionated and sassy know
your opinion on yourself and we've we've
loved working with you Kevin over the
past nine years everyone's come here as
well at oh my god there's a bunch of
people books it wouldn't be a GameSpot
farewell without some people monsters to
come oh we've all had a wonderful nine
years working with your governor who
wouldn't be gamespot farewell would at
least at one more secret montage so mary
has provided us with one so let's let's
check out your secret montage hello
everybody did you miss us I miss my
viewers this is Kevin dorothy charming
as ever Kevin man word welcome GameSpot
viewers I'm Kevin Ord I'm joined by
Justin Calvert and as a mysterious
floating brown-box
Metal Gear Solid 4 gone to the Patriots
is likely the most technically stunning
video game
Resident Evil 6 is sloppy and random
you've never quite seen a mess like this
demon souls might be the hardest game
you'll play from all year but it's also
one of the best where The Witcher 2 sort
of sputtered to a halt The Witcher 3 is
always and crescendo crafting battle
scenarios and constantly one of the last
you could level certain criticisms of
Mass Effect 3 but the flaws aren't too
consequential in a game that does so
much with so much elegance play around
in unity and to charge people money for
did you know what does it mean have I
found Kevin's on the street you are
coming now I'm gonna make sure that the
game whoa right on top of me you're all
terrible all terrible there are a lot of
personal space issues in this office
today
dragon is killed he is the body is
falling down and I am going to absorb
his soul
[Music]
[Applause]